[Musik]
hallo ich jeden meine süßen ich habe
heute ein richtig geniales rezept im
gepäck nämlich eine maulwurf torte oder
ein maulwurf kuchen aber vom blech der
vorteil ist erstens geht total schnell
sein das ist anfänger geeignet und
dritten tier habt einfach man sich
drüber
und drittens ok sammeln und drittens ihr
habt viel viel mehr stücke als um eine
runde kuppel torte also wir fangen jetzt
mal direkt an mit dem teig das ist ein
einfacher urteil
dafür benötigen wir diese folgenden
zutaten ganz normales weizenmehl
außerdem zucker backpulver und eine
prise salz hier habe ich sonnenblumenöl
könnte auch gerne raps wir nehmen er
mich dies lauwarm außerdem bacau das ist
der stark enthüllte und ach ja und ich
gebe alles in meine rührschüssel und
früher das miteinander
[Musik]
und wieso wird es keine gespräche weil
es einfach wie sie mit der hand geht und
nicht jeder hat eine küchenmaschine zu
hause
[Musik]
so der teig ist schon fertig ich habe
jetzt nur minute gerührt und so ist ja
so schon ziemlich ja gefehlt das wort
also heute stimmt irgendwas nicht mit
mir
ich geb dir jetzt auf jeden fall hier in
meine backform ich werde euch die maße
und den infobox schreiben ich hab die
backform mit auf meinen backblech
gegeben und darunter noch ein backpapier
und jetzt einfach einführung ab
streichen
genau elastisch das war das wort was ich
gesucht habe
[Musik]
so und detail kommt jetzt bei 190 grad
ober und unterhitze in den vorgeheizten
backofen für ca 18 bis maximal 20
minuten macht aber auf jeden fall die
städtischen probe
[Musik]
der boden ist abgekühlt aber wir machen
jetzt erstmal diese typische maulwurf
kuchen füllung und das ist ja die auf
geschlagene sahne mit dem schokoraspeln
und natürlich bananen und ich zeige ich
jetzt hier mal die zutaten ich habe als
kalte schlagsahne da gebe ich euch
gleich noch mal einen schönen tisch
außerdem natürlich sahne fest für den
geschmack unbedingt vanille extrakt wer
den ich da hat entweder bei uns im shop
kaufen oder vanillezucker nehmen aber
nicht vanillinzucker hier habe ich noch
etwas puderzucker das ist nur optional
für die süße natürlich unsere
schokoraspeln und ein paar bananen damit
die sahne auf jeden fall schön steif
wird und nicht entgehen sich
zusammensackt ist es wie gesagt ganz
wichtig dass die aus dem kühlschrank
kommt er darf jetzt nicht als zehn
minuten auf zimmertemperatur stehen und
dann verarbeitet werden und was sie auch
immer ganz gerne mache ich gebe den
schneebesen aufsatz und die römisches
hilfe 30 minuten in den kühlschrank oder
für 15 minuten in den tiefkühlschrank
dann kann nichts schiefgehen leute ist
kann nichts schief geht und jetzt
schlage ich das langsam an die immer
höher mit der stufe und las man in
extrakt und sahne fest ein rätsel
[Musik]
nach ungefähr zwei minuten ist die sahne
schön standfest und an der stelle
einfach die schokoraspeln noch mal
einarbeiten wie lamy
[Musik]
die queen kommt jetzt ganz kurz zur
seite und wir machen weiter mit dem
abkühlen schokobrunnen und dann nehmt
euch jetzt am besten ein tortenring
messer damit wir auch den bug raum
entfernt können und der jetzt nicht so
am tag lebt und ihr euch den halt nicht
kaputt reißt so einmal den bug rahm
entfernen und jetzt könnt ihr einfach
nur den boden auf die arbeitsplatte also
nicht stürzen sondern legen ich habe
hier in meinem back gramm extra eine
ecke so ein bisschen angeschrägt das
team einfach dazu also genau für solche
fälle
damit ihr das eben ganz leicht runter
ziehen könnte und ist nichts kaputt
gegangen aber ich wollte es irgendwo zu
holen
auch das jetzt klingt aber das recht
cool ja also muss ehrlicherweise
geschickt es ist werbung das produkt ist
doch einfach so geil ich hab mir
angestellt genau das ist etwas
eingeschränkt und es bleibt halt
gleichmäßig dadurch dass alles klappt es
oft genug der werbung wir machen jetzt
weiter ich werde erst mal meinen
backpapier entfernen das macht ihn so
einer bewegung ich kann es nicht
beschreiben ich muss euch zeigen haben
so schwenk mal runter
[Musik]
so schaut man den finger an den seiten
und so trägt immer das backpapier weg
[Musik]
sonst nämlich den oberen deckel einmal
akzeptiert jetzt einmal durchtrennt und
gibt das tier so rein gekündet in meine
schüssel
das ist halt so typisch für den maulwurf
kuchen dass man die dann später über die
sahne creme gibt
[Musik]
zum nächsten schritt nehme ich mir jetzt
meine eckige skateboard und toom ein
boden da drauf wir brauchen mehr
irgendwie einen festen stand müssen dass
er gleich auch anheben können und dann
nochmal den bug rantum herum
[Musik]
und der rest erklärt sich eigentlich von
selbst wir geben jetzt einfach die
bananen auf den teig dann die sahne
creme und dann unsere krümelchen nicht
mit der schale und ich hab so den trick
mal gelernt bzw hat das nicht nur sogar
ein kleiner bruder und eine schwester
die em wieder dass man wenn man die
banane schält dass diese ich weiß auch
gar nicht wie man sie nennt das die auch
mit abgehen automatisch diese haut müsse
ja ich weiß gar nicht wie man es nennt
das ist der begriff dafür meist zu sehen
das glaube ich nicht
[Musik]
da fertig ist unsere maulwurf torte vom
blech und die kann jetzt eigentlich für
eine halbe stunde in den kühlschrank
und dann könnt ihr den bug raum
entfernen und sofort servieren und ich
finde das rezept einfach so genial weil
es schnell geht der teig ist schnell
gerührt die sahne schon aufgeschlagen
alles schnell hergerichtet und ja falls
mal besuch kommt irgendwie unangekündigt
und er sagt ich bin der stunde da dann
mache ich mich direkt an und dann
schaffe ich das auch in der stunde
und ganz wichtig ist dass er das jetzt
abdeckt weil die oberfläche sollte jetzt
nicht austrocknen ich mache jetzt
einfach ein buch drüber
und wie gesagt in der heim stunden im
kühlschrank ist das ganze dann auch
schon fertig und ich hoffe dass ihr das
fleißig nach macht und hat aber in die
infobox da stehen die genauen
mengenangaben da steht alles was hier im
video verwendet habe und wenn ihr bis
hingeschaut habt ein dörfchen nach oben
da lassen darf man nicht so schnell
reden am ende hab sowieso an gewinnen am
ende so schön zu reden
ich glaube dass diese vorfreude dass wir
dann das shooting machen und diese
entziehen drehen und dann essen können
rosa okay ich wünsche euch jetzt noch
einen wunderschönen tag und wir
schreiben in den kommentaren miteinander
bis bald
[Musik]
das